anyway for those just joining um we do
have a match
starting against uh very strong player
from vietnam
and he's i think he's an i am
but he's gm strength especially in blitz
will i be giving him time odds if
anything he should be giving me odds
anyway oh he's playing e4 uh
wait i didn't prepare against this i
thought he was gonna play
i mean i have to try a stafford i think
also hopefully the layout's okay
is he gonna refute the stafford
oh he's avoiding the saffron okay so we
have a four nights
honestly i prepared london for him and
nothing else
on the black side okay so we're doing
kind of the same
knight maneuver on the king's side
probably bishop here so if d4 i have
this move
27
maybe c6 first
okay i'm just trying to play solidly and
quickly
try really really hard to stay focused
here
let's move rookie a coming
bishop e6 and d5 might happen then i
drop back
so i want to put the rook in the center
maybe eventually go for like d5
i don't think he really wants to sack
small time advantage problem is i don't
know what to do here
if i play d5 it gets really messy
changes this move just ensuring the
rooks aren't blocked
okay what to do
maybe maneuver the knight eventually to
e6
i think you compact buffalo gifting five
subs
okay we're gonna put the knight or the
bishop back
it's kind of a game of cat and mouse
i really don't want to get like too long
time wow he sucks
okay so takes
i guess the issue is knight f5
so probably takes first an h7
and then i want to do this and this
okay queen e7
maybe takes first
and this is still possible king h8
bishop f7
her cure i'm alive though
e4
okay now takes
uh
the time is going to be very relevant
i should be a little bit better here
annoying move
this move
i want to play rook t2 it's all about
activity
and time
oh no
no i'm getting mated that's a good game
too
ah y'all played me he's so good in these
situations
okay that was a good start though i had
my chances
okay rematch good game okay let's play
one of these
oh he's playing nothing which i prepared
oh he's playing the elephant he has like
a youtube
course about this
um i think i'm supposed to take
wait a minute
there's a bunch of lines that's better
playable
i think this is one of them
okay keep some composure here
that's a weird kind of development for
both of us
like the queen on b6 knight on d3
knight d4 may be coming
play bishop e3
and your b4
so b4 there's queen f5
should probably take that
oh no
[Music]
that was a blunder oh wow
no
okay how bad is this okay this move
this is probably really bad but
in queen h2 king here i don't see the
clear follow-up
the problem is bishop c4 is coming
this is so unpleasant uh queen d3
rookie
so i want the knight to be here
i'm about to get smashed though
and the hope is that somehow he doesn't
have any breakthrough
there's even beach bishop tree i taken
[Music]
maybe it's okay
i mean what to do this move
my queen keeps getting kicked and he's
going to have bishop's e4 coming
play this move
if if this i have this move defending
one
it should be losing but it's getting
weird
so take skinny 2 takes
save the bishop
i'm still alive
like barely
c5 maybe b3
no c5 i take on b5
take that wait too many things are
hanging
my queen's trapped what is this
dark magic
to try this
no
please don't see mates please
okay so i have two rooks for queen
bishop
knight not the greatest situation
probably have to pray for some
stalemates
no no
okay okay
i didn't flag i see the don't flag emote
but i was kind of rough so down to
okay i prepared for london
oh he's capable of playing a lot of
different things
okay queen's game time
so with this line i usually play um
usually go for a very solid setup
g8 97 coming
[Music]
yeah this is still all theory defend h
pawn
and the plan is to play bishop d6 h6
yeah this is all skill prep there's
actually a really cool idea
potentially coming up if he takes so
takes takes
takes takes e4 i have knight f4 allowing
the fork and then queen e6
and if it takes i have queen g4
and then knight e1 i can take on e1 and
then white only has f3 to survive there
so we're going into it kind of
there's this move too but then i take
and it's nice for black
yeah he's clearly not prepared here
[Music]
i mean e4 looks good just visually
because
up he's not playing it so that's also
playable
i think i have this move
like takes a knight h4
even in h4 right away
wait there's um some bishop f5 idea
let's repeat once
yeah this actually traps a rook
might as well just win material
um
yeah let's not overthink this preserve
time
so i'm up the exchange it's my best
position so far
i have takes i have bishop here
that wants to be here
interesting
some c5 idea
maybe not
play this move
slightly annoying
i do this
not the move i want to play but
so if takes i take a knight of four
i'm making a mess out of this
there's actually possibility of this
move with the threat of knight f4
he might move his king here
okay i think this is okay now i can
probably take
wait no let's take here
i got forked okay it's getting wild
should still be better
cutting this made in two threats
oh yeah this should be winning
it's really hard to stop queen h1
okay plenty of time
white's pawns are funny
okay okay i want a game no adoption
let's go i was uh i mean
a good chunk of the opening there was
prep
like opening early middle game uh
so that worked out nicely thank you joel
subbing with prime
i have some vague memory of e5 but i
think it's
this first and then knight f6 e5
nice one thank you credited lime
appreciate that
i vaguely remember studying this line
probably not the specific position but i
remember the idea with e5
like early with the knight here because
if we ever trade then it's just good for
white
in combination with bishop e3
it's actually hard for black to develop
completely
there's no knife 6
that's logical queen d4
if i take
maybe queen d4
so accepting double pawns
but in making rook t1 possible
hitting the bishop
and d5 makes sense
f4 there's knight h6
bishop h3
it's a weird position kind of hard to
understand
i want to play this and this
so g6 i'm going to play f5 it's kind of
a cool pawn sack
because the goal the goal is to like
disrupt development in some way and now
this move
starting to trap the rook rook get a
castle queen side
bishop g7 i take the knight
uh knight c6 queen h4 or quindi oh wow
but i have queen h4 or oh that move
good move
oh what is this
i mean queen h4 probably
we'll trade knight h6 queen h6
i'm worse here
i do have queen e3
i'm down so much time too
so i'm down the pawn position is really
good for that though
and it was a cool position rook take g5
was nice for him
not h4 coming
hoping for some eventual tactics with
the g-file
not happening
there is some weird bishop d5 though
[Music]
let's take
i'm trying to hold on it's not going to
last though
[Music]
so now i'm done two pawns assumed to be
three
okay at least i got a passer
yeah well played there is no way to
catch the pawn like rook and king were
out of play
good game
okay so three to one
yeah so he's playing a king's indian
attack which i did not prepare for
but um i mean this is a setup i usually
play
was that a mouse slip that looks like a
mouse slip
because usually white plays e4 but maybe
he's just playing more slowly
that's kind of a very close solid
position for both sides
preventing knight g3
this position requires patience requires
moving quickly
might play c4 and try and get the knight
to e4
knight d2
[Music]
i think it's harder to play for white
though
and go for pawn e4 i still have knight
g3 on v4
interesting
i want to play c4 here
i don't see anything wrong with it
because if takes i take hit the queen
and then regain the pawn
um
i'll take and put the knight here
like white's actually standing up nicely
to attack on the king's side
like c5 i lose b6
maybe this move i do bishop c4
i didn't calculate takes but i assume
this and
it should be okay queen v2 rook b8
and knight wants to come in
it should be a slightly better position
for black
but still very tense b pawn's a bit
backwards
um
okay so i might lose b6 but then i'll
get a lot of initiative
let me takes first
upon getting so let's play this first
okay so outside passer up on time
um
take your
just simplifying
oh okay i was completely blind to that
oh that's not good
man don't leave me
don't hurt me
i played this move
it's so weird like knights are so tricky
knight g7
oh
i'm almost getting mated almost winning
on time
king h52 mates
okay it's a draw
i maybe could have gone for like a dirty
flag but uh
i think a draw is kind of a fair result
i was probably losing at some point
there
i was geeking good game i felt like i
was
much better at some point but i'll let
something slip
okay so this is um one thing i prepared
ooh uh i'll play h4
i prepared more knight c6
okay now we're kind of out of prep
i usually have this position without the
inclusion of these these pawn moves
so if all the pawns were back i would
know what i'm doing but
i mean this should favor me because uh
king side is a bit weaker
um i can take and play queen a4
now i'm winning a piece
yeah typical idea in this line
okay this worked out a tricky opening
i think he was just uh
just not booked up tried to improvise
it backfired
i still have to like keep my composure
here
i know he's very tricky
i gave a lecture on on knight c3
sicilian
for st louis chess club a few years ago
um now i covered i covered d4 on move
three
but h4 is an interesting inclusion and
then later d4
which we got in this game
yeah so he's fighting probably bishop d3
and d5
i'm looking at 95 here
i don't know how crazy i want to go
knight d5 is kind of cool though
because i hit the bishop i prevent black
from playing pawn d5
not afraid of taking
even bishop bishop here
again i don't see anything wrong with
this
idea e6 knight b6
i don't care about b2 just rick b1
like sometimes when you're up a piece
you either want to simplify or just keep
as much attack and initiative as
possible
that's really hard to deal with this
actually
up about the middle on the clock there's
also bishop b6 ideas
um bishop e6 i could end up like
windmilling the queen
yeah this is a really really nice
opening yeah just here
i mean there is takes no
because if takes i take and then the
night hangs
in 26 93
[Music]
the queen is not getting trapped muppet
rook and a knight in this position
he's gonna play on probably castling
i have a lot of time to think too
three looks nicer
oh the bishop hangs the good thing about
being up a rook
and a bishop is that when you hang the
bishop you're still up a rook
let's just not give away any more pieces
for free
uh maybe rook here first and then queen
g3
and this is getting weird now
yeah very resilient player
have this move not the move i want to
play
my king's still in the center i just
want to castle
okay so now i've i'm only up to exchange
i better not lose this he's fought on
really well
i can take here
bishop g4 bishop g4 f3
my queen's out of play though
wait my time
oh that was terrible
no
oh no my sub expired oh no
stanley please
okay
couldn't you just use a sponge oh at
least i didn't lose that
yeah i was up a rookie on a piece i
thought he was going to resign after
like 12 moves
what was that game man
i still gained six rating points for
that
oh man
okay i have hand sanitizer
but i have to preserve it probably for
some more games let's play d5
i think he's gonna play london now
yeah so i prepared this he plays queen
c2
and then knight h5 bishop e5 f6
and then bishop g3 takes an e5 this is
all
engine preparation
it's pretty obscure line because most
people don't play
uh queen c2 this is still prep
so white can't take here because takes
takes takes takes
and then queen takes dixa1 is
unstoppable
i think i looked a little bit further
from this position
uh like e4 is one of the
[Music]
main ideas
i think just takes in bishop e6
okay i vaguely remember i'm not supposed
to take right away but
okay now i'm on my own
bishop b4
this bishop here
yeah queen a4 so i can't play this
because bishop b5
so i'm thinking like king f7
it's weird but
why not
yeah it's going to be a fight i think i
got a slight advantage from the opening
probably threatening i was finding that
so i think i'll artificial castle
and if i get a good position i really
have to like stay focused
can't get too relaxed even
with the time advantage too there should
be three coming
so i defend
some case where this could be a nice
move
not yet maybe rook here
might be five
let's play this
yeah i was sending this move bishop
wasn't defended there
if i take
not sure about this i think we're going
to simplify a lot
or not
you probably want to include b5
even e3 at some points
rook c2
knight c3 coming
ooh good move
no ah that was really bad
i blundered everything uh let's resign
momentarily
okay ah that was a nice position i just
cracked
got too long time allowed 94.
okay two to five it's not too bad
it's still better than expected kind of
yeah oh no my everything
so this worked out well take him down
it's rabbit season oh thanks for that
uh mr kilo
this should be okay bishop g4 i have f3
so the idea it's actually a common idea
in these lines to play queen f3 here
in between move e6 and then
because here i have to play knight e2
okay now i have this move bishop e5
i even have c3 takes and then d4
like the bishop might get trapped here
duck season oh duck season yeah all the
animals
what to play here
queen h3 season
okay people can debate what's which
season it is
i want it to be mating season i take and
then
let's play d3 actually bishop b3
flexible move
yeah i'm not sure how great this is it's
interesting though
getting these uh it's kind of weird
positions from the opening
frozen winning season oh yeah that's my
favorite season
tis the season i play f4 here
my pieces are clumsy
like queen c2
and then like d3 f4 eventually
okay like before i have to play queen b1
it's almost really bad for me
yeah i feel like i'm getting out played
a four maybe coming
whoa it's in thanks for all the content
to get me through night shift
thanks for that i really appreciate that
15
yeah how many people are like watching
during their their night shift
or their bishop shift
i force probably not the best idea
just castle and king should be here and
then
then later like f4 f5 got some attack
going
he wants to play d5
i do have a time advantage
light should maneuver this way
oh my pawn's weak
probably should have seen that coming
g5 idea
now it can be pleasant
so i have to trade off bishops first
and this bishop's completely out of
place i think i'm okay sacking the
exchange
my d-pawn's weak though
it's all about time
no no
no
it's almost stalemate but not quite
okay oh that's a good game
it was a cool position from the opening
and then things went terribly wrong
and the games are close
i'm getting outplayed hey eric how's it
going various positions though
oh it's going it's going decently
staying alive
i'm trying not to get too tilted
yeah he's so good in like these time
scramble situations
i feel like the bullet is going to be a
lot more difficult
bishop d6 here b3
i think i studied this at some point so
if takes i have e4
i'm not sure if i studied this though
just gonna go with the flow
so hitting the pawn also kind of tying
down the bishop so
bishop c4 is slightly more difficult to
play
it's interesting
shift takes takes takes i have takes
then castles takes rook g1
i kind of wanted to prepare this move
too
yeah a good move
if i take on d5
and this move
i'm trying to preserve time
okay g4 coming
yeah very unusual position here
some idea knight t3
opponent wants to meet me so i have this
move
now knight d3 maybe queen h4
very hard to understand this position
this is a key square
keep the bishop defended oh
the knight wasn't defended
i can't be missing things like that
not going to give up
the problem is white can just castle and
then the king's hard to get to
maybe c4 here or c5
i'm just trying to like open up lines
eventually get to the king make it a bit
complicated
oh what to do bishop bishop here
this is really unpleasant
so rook f6 i don't think works
queen e5 doesn't work so my queen
defends from a distance
rookie 4 might work
so first check oh king c1
that's a problem
it's actually a really big problem
i think it's just losing now
um let's take
and there's some still me tricks
actually
like here oh i have a pawn though
oh it's so close
oh there there were some tricks there
but he was clearly
very aware of them good game
i think the the next one might be our
last blitz game because we
we said uh one hour of blitz
uh let's play wait let's play this move
what did i prepare play this move
i've been liking the openings i'm
getting
oh he plays elephant again
okay so we'll go into the same line as
before
yeah i'm just going for some kind of
solid setup
this is probably not a great move
i mean we can make it very dry if this
move no that thing's a piece
now what to do maybe this move
so bishop here rookie one
it's actually a very tense position a
lot of things happening here
play rook d1
this pawn is kind of hanging he might
just take it
that's just a free pawn we'll see if he
sees it though he's been hanging for
since queen f5 was played
that's not the end of the world it's
just a pawn
grab this move
i'm trying to target the queen
the queen doesn't have too many squares
if here i move here
discovery if here maybe 95
okay there's some compensation
g6
so one calculation this takes takes
takes and then takes
95.
so queen h5 there's g6
taking immediately doesn't look like
it's working i mean queen g2
maybe queen e4
doesn't look good though let's try it
i just gotta move quick
so queen b2 i take on h7 okay
still down upon life goes on
and this looks pretty bad but
let's do it
b6 b3
it's actually a really difficult
position to play
oh i didn't see that
oh i should see night moves like that
okay how bad is this now
oh this is really bad
no i'm just losing everything
so i'm down two exchanges and soon to be
another bishop
okay good game
that was rough good game
okay i think we do we move on to bullet
or we hop on call
to um
kind of commiserate my defeat
yeah stop the count he's tough because
if you give him a chance to start
hurting you then he starts hurting you
it's hard to come back i'll have to
figure out what to do against this
elephant
it's an opening i should have prepared
um i mean on the bright side
i don't think i lost rating i think like
two to eight was maybe an expected
result
okay we're gonna do bullet now and then
then we'll hop on call after
the games and maybe he can teach me a
thing or two
uh in the form of not just beating me
consistently
okay it's bullet time okay so it's eight
to two overall
i have to move much much quicker
oh he's not expecting bishop f4
man he's 3100 in bullet that's insane
if i can win one i'll be happy
cutting this navy
uptime
oh i got forked well played
d5 while still kind of alive
it's a weird position nice for doing
some work
there we go
no no
oh i didn't realize my time i was almost
surviving
final position was losing though okay
we'll play a london
i'll play one of these again
okay happy with the white openings
never mind he's playing this well
there goes my stuff
again with the knights i'm trying to be
tricky
can i get the fork
really trying to be tricky
how many pounds am i down
probably too many
ah there goes my thing
mainly my hope okay that was a weird
game
yeah he played well okay there goes two
um okay we'll play one of these
what is going on here i'm so confused
what's my rook doing
and i was hanging there
this might be okay knight d4
i won the thing
i don't know what just happened there
i'm up a queen but i lost so much
material
i'm winning pawns winning a lot of pawns
i'm down on time
i'm down way too much material despite
so many pawns
and a queen i got mated
oh that was unfortunate that's a funny
game though
okay let's play this opening again
play one of these
um does this move work
okay threatening this never mind
solid position i mean it's just about
equal
oh
i'm down so much time
okay
and i just have a worse position
okay maybe now it's not so bad i'm just
down too much time
no i got mated what i got mated i was
also flagging he was going to dirty flag
me that's so sad
that's so sad oh
i was up a fawn i really came back from
the end game too i thought it was worse
okay just finding cheap stuff
it's kind of london-like
good move
again i'm down way too much time
and i'm losing a piece
what to do
i'm fighting
no i can't move there i can set up the
trap because the bishop existed
and he has 20 seconds what was that
i really tried to set up the thing i was
in the wrong corner though
okay
all i want to do is win one game it's
only goal
good i like the position actually
not entirely sure what i'm doing here
okay a4 is hard to stop i might be
winning material
there we go
i'm still not on time there we go
why is this so difficult
no i'm going to lose on time
okay at least it's a draw oh i could
have
i could have pre-moved mated by taking
on that fates
oh that's such an easy pre-movement too
no
i could have taken king f7 knight g6
mate
oh i didn't see it quickly enough
okay at least uh i drew a game
so it's some success right i gained some
rating from that
pog yeah we can celebrate get some
confetti
yeah let's go
also what's going on he disconnected can
i abort
oh it'll auto abort wait what it says
what is this look at what it says
it says no adoption i can't wait
auto resigner auto aborts this is very
ambiguous
aborted okay so looks like he had some
connection issues there
um hopefully he didn't rage quit
after that draw okay we're gonna have a
b3 line
okay yeah this is kind of a trendy line
people are playing
knight f6
oh no am i already losing
i might be that's crazy
i'm in trouble with this move
starting made in one and i have three
i'll play
this move doesn't do much though
play g5 thinking this
trying to fight
there's take some queen d4
there
ah there goes my rook and he's just
faster
and stronger
hey it's a raid hey jude hey jude
welcome back thanks for the raid you're
just joining i'm getting slightly
crushed
um or very crushed
okay i resign with 0.6 seconds left
so for the raiders joining i am uh i
currently have a match against
minlai very very strong player
um i feel like he's just toying around
with me now
but i've had some fun games it's a
learning experience
actually have a nice setup now
play this move
oh no i blundered no because knight f3
is a threat
oh that's so sad
so i'll take and pray
damn but every game he's up on time by
like 10 seconds out of the opening
and take this
any hope
f7 was a bit weak but he sees it
oh i didn't see the knight could take
okay i resigned that was rough
we're moving on
it's like a caro con type thing
um i'm losing the pawn
yeah he's out playing me like on
position and clock
so it's really tough to create chances
just have to keep moving forward
good move
okay
again no adoption but
i'd like to at least win a bullet game i
drew a bullet game what is this move
okay whoa it's five dollars
eric this guy beats hikaru and is one of
the most strong items you are also a
strong i am don't
let this get you down you are great
thanks for the supportive words i
appreciate that
um yeah i'm trying to have the right
mindset take this
okay
feeling good here hard to stop broke h4
how do i mate though queen defends
[Music]
not seeing it no
and now i'm looting okay wait it's still
interesting
wow i might still be winning
or to stop broke f6
that's very important that i kept my
cool there
i'm going to try one on the clock
easy to make quick moves
oh he's gonna do this oh oh he didn't
try it
i thought he was gonna try it
okay hey i want a game let's go i feel
so accomplished
15 points i think i won back all the
points i lost too
let's go let's make it two in a row
so much hype
took a lot of work there
i just lose a pawn i just lost a pawn
thank you compact buffalo appreciate
that i lost a piece
he didn't take it though
i just have to get him tilted
oh my thing okay man not the highest
quality game
blundering a lot wait what
how bad is this
it's probably pretty bad but i'm alive
oh it's probably really bad
no i'm getting mated well played that
was a cool sequence
ah that was a mouse slip
stafford gambit no it's just a
italian i guess
g4 move
hi hi how's it going
uh let's play that
nice looking position
whoa that's stephen gray
i'm trying
composure is very important
in this risky position
oh that was a great move
there goes my thing look at this
let's try and set up one of these uh
dirty traps
we'll just give away all the pawns
now he's not taking it why is he not
taking it
oh i wanted to set that up too
okay oh that was rough
hey jin hick thank you continuing the
sub gift
you got from sexy car appreciate that
okay um
play one of these
no my queen it's not the end of the
world even though
it kind of is
winning this pond or not
what is this
okay so i'm missing a lot of my pieces
here
mainly my queen
i'm trying to be tricky really trying
but now i'm just kind of being sad
no
there i resigned well played
okay three man three and a half to
nineteen and a half
this is rough hug
okay life goes on though life goes on
i've been liking the positions i get
from this line
i meant to play f4 play this
no my pawns
it's still some hope not too much hope
though
okay
no
oh that was a cool game though i almost
uh almost
got tricky there sort of not really
okay i just want to win one more
[Music]
one more game
okay it's a pleasant position time is
okay
i'm just trying to stay solid 93 ideas
f5
no i got forked
that's so sad it was such a clean game
too
look at this move
no nope no
okay i think we're approaching the end
maybe we'll do one more
i think that the time has probably run
out by now but i know he's chasing
some kind of adoption so why am i
playing this
play this move this is a good opening
okay
oh no okay maybe it's not so bad
maybe it is though
[Music]
well played
okay i feel like a punching bag
good game though i think we might hop on
call
hey min yes i'm here you hear me
i can hear you good games though you
really you were beating up on me in the
the bullet portion
just it's hard to keep up with the speed
well i don't know i mean like one thing
that
my channel is my channel is something
that really really feeling bad that i
cannot adopt
but okay what i want to say is that like
actually i am not
like ready to take a lot of
responsibility like
against one of the like huge like most
famous channel
in the chess community so i say that
no i appreciate that
yeah i mean i know you you have
experience uh in these matches against
like akaru
and danya uh so it's still it was on an
honor for me to uh
to play you and and uh and not get
adopted so that was my
my goal for today well actually you're
playing well i mean in some bliss games
like you'll find some really good
resources
some first game i must say that i was
like really lucky to survive
the first games come
well prepared hello again eric i have
troubles in most of my opening games
somehow you don't find a way to you know
like finish me i don't know but there
are a lot of way i see you can play some
better
moves sure yeah i felt like the opening
was my strong point
and then if i didn't get like a
a good or winning position from the
opening i was getting outplayed like
much later
uh in in a lot of games like even even
if i got a good position you were so
tricky and
in coming back and uh and just keeping
the game going
like that one game i think i was winning
on move
10 you know which game i'm referring to
i was up like a rook and a knight
and maybe if you want we can like we can
make an analysis board too
yeah sure to analyze you can invite me i
mean
i think i'm ready and i think my viewers
will be happy to see that thing
sure uh let me yeah i can say like a
game yeah like a game you play with me
i mean like you play queen a4 and you
win a night early right
and then you get yourself yeah now i
mean like somehow i can get back to the
game
i don't even know why uh
yeah i think i got too relaxed i have
this problem when i get winning
positions i'll just
like lose focus assume the position will
play itself and
i think this is natural though like when
you get winning positions sometimes it's
it's easy to be careless
yeah i mean like that i think that's why
laskar himself said that the hardest to
win position
is the winning position i can say i mean
it's very true
when you've got winning so somehow you
can get careless or simply you will be
like
okay this winning let's relax but you
know at
this point a lot of time you can i mean
like there can be some tricks but your
opponent that you may miss i guess
did you do any specific preparation for
me
no oh you can see that i mean like i
trying to play like random
well you were playing like different
things than you usually play
um well yeah normally i mean like you
should know that i played
on most of the game bliss of this game
with london yes
and then for black so i play sicilian
names
also i play slav but today i simply
didn't play any any of those things
yeah i did like very light preparation
for you so
there were a few openings i was
more expecting and then but a lot of
what you play like i just didn't predict
and then i had to kind of rely on
what i've studied in the past
okay so
um wait a minute i think i brought in
the wrong game
um but maybe if you want to analyze like
whatever openings we encountered
like i um i i did a lot of preparation
in the london for you
oh sure and i was curious
um i guess we did have one game
that went down this line
yeah if i see three couldn't be cause
you you play this all the time
um and then knight h5 right
yeah especially f6 and yeah this game i
think you can win even earlier
you should be e3 cd4 can you see my
moves right you see my moves
yeah so if you find me in the gameplay
edifying you play e5 here right
e5 the five knight g3
chase maybe five i think now you're even
better than me i guess
you should be two in the game i think
you can't even play something
i think e4 in the game is great but on
d4
i mean you can play c5 there and you're
much better
much better so this was all preparation
through e4 um and i prepared it like a
few hours ago with engine
um but i i didn't look like further
beyond this but bishop c5 is a nice move
here
yes i mean i guess the epsom square is
really
really bad and it's true
now the you know pressure on the d5
pawns and the bishop and the dust square
have no opponent
i think everything just seems to be so
perfect for you
yeah it's very true and probably at
least winning a pawn here
uh it looks like you your video actually
the call may have just dropped
can you still hear me uh-oh
it's uh the internet gambit oh no
i'm sorry sorry this is my bed i can say
yeah i know it happened like in in one
of our games but it happened uh
i guess before the game actually started
yes luckily it was tough
yep yeah okay i mean like this line is
pretty strong i don't know i mean i
seen the one place one earlier but i bet
that next time if you play like
cd4 i should take the c pawn i guess so
i prepared this a little bit as well um
i'd play knight before here before
queen b3 and then bishop okay
yeah it might be irritating i won't play
not e3 i think it's just equalizing
um i was gonna play
e6 maybe probably
oh yeah i did look at this there's a
weird line knight h4
and then i can play knight c2
idea after it takes takes takes and i
keep the uh
the bishop and then
i was looking this at this early earth
engine because it looks kind of natural
for you to play
king d2 here but then after rook c8
blocks much better because bishop b4 is
hard to stop
yeah should be four it's quite strong
for you i think now you're better the
bishop on g3
is sure that he doesn't do anything yet
in a nice four obviously
yeah completely shitty so like this is
the main thing i prepared because i i
know like queen c2 is it's a bit offbeat
and um i was really excited to get like
some of these lines with uh with the
early night h5
yes so i i was curious
oh yeah go ahead i mean actually nice
five it's a nice idea
i see some guys playing this against me
but most of the time they play bishop e5
f6 which should be three and they play
something like e6 actually e6 or g6 yeah
yes they play mostly easiest g6 and i'm
fine after that
and also after qc2 so after this move
i'm ready to like face some quite
passive position
i actually play with white i mean this
light a lot of time
i um i looked up the last time we played
on chess.com
before before this match and before like
the
recent arena kings and we had played one
time before
in this line i think i played g6 and you
you outplayed me pretty smoothly
um because i tried to like get bishop f5
but i know you have this like in between
move
with takes on c5 and i didn't want to go
into that line i wanted to
have something a bit more concrete well
maybe i don't know but when i play this
squishy 2 so mostly people play g6
most people play just against me right
maybe 257 and then
this little letter and then castling i
think likes to fight and
the thing i can say about the position
is that white is having quite
a passive but solid position so actually
you know
normally we're not playing that for
white i mean white is the one who need
to play something more active and
need to fight for you know initiative
but in this lie
i mean basically it's pretty rare since
white is looking for equalize
so obviously this is pretty rare
also here like i play this light in
bullet against manuscripts you know the
world champion and lee
and i mean like they placed this line
against me as well g4
oh interesting the idea is trying to
see it next and if you know in the
future you can do this one
trying to neutralize the bishop in d3
i guess that's very logical yeah
i was curious because i i have obviously
played the london
too i was wondering if there is any
reason
you you play c3 instead of e3
like of course you're going into this
queen c2 line but um
this has been what i like i enjoy as
white
and then i think this is the main light
right so like queen b6 it's not c3 right
so queen b6 knight c3 right or what's
probably more common is knight c6 first
and then knight d2 is kind of the the
wrinkle in the move order
because then queen b6 says do you take
c5
oh yeah but i guess it's the type of
thing like if if you've been playing the
other move order you don't necessarily
need to
to book up on uh on this specific line
yes actually the thing is that like i
mean
the reason why i don't play that lie
since i [ __ ] it's
quite irritating i don't know but i
think like now cd4 should be five for
black
yes i don't know maybe i'm wrong but i
don't know the
clear variation here 84 like i know
like the idea like g6 i guess it should
be 757 i don't see it nice
interesting i find this setup for
like quite easy to play for him that's
why i trying to stay away from this line
yeah i thought there's a lot of lines
where knight b5 can happen
a6 and a4 exactly
and then if i can get kind of this setup
then there's a nice kind of bind where
it's hard to actually remove this knight
but maybe it's still
it's still a fight maybe it is
but actually the reason why i play
london every game actually
almost like in every game and bless i
mean like i am not a lunatic specialist
i can say that about like you or andrew
down some guys who play
i mean mostly london but for me i just
play london like in
online just for an easy opening like you
kind of get the same
positions that you're familiar with yeah
i think that's important uh in blitz to
have a
kind of a comfort opening yeah
in yeah if i play classical or rapid i
will play the main line play the queen
scan bit like normal
i don't know when i play you know some
bliss games i just trying to offer you
know an easy opening
i don't need to think much in opening
since actually i'm
quite i mean confident in my middle game
play
yeah the middle game and the like
tactics time scrambles i feel like
you're you're very very strong
um that's definitely an area i need to
work on more
there is another opening i guess i just
wanted to show you like just a cool
opening idea
um it may have been let me see if i can
find the game
um it was in the queen's gambit declined
and we went very very deep into some
kind of preparation and maybe i don't
know like this one
is this like you playing the game or
something yeah this a6 line
and then takes takes bishop g5 yes and
actually i know awesome
about this only oh okay 27
37 we should be seven i know this from
the game minus i think
in the world rapid 2019 and he beat some
russian guy with black i forget it's
been a very trendy opening like this
early a6 idea and then
going for bishop e6 and sometimes even
the bishop goes to d6 and
you put the queen on c7 yes it is so
there's all these different sets
something like e3 97 we should be three
we should be successful
well qc2 here and here equini7 here if
it was not mistaken
the idea is like this and c5
interesting yeah i guess they're like
you you hold the c
pawn back because you you want to play
c5 in one move
yes if you play c6 it will transpose to
the crossbar
and constructors that we play in the
game but c5 can be another idea
i don't know it's interesting i mean
like i am not especially in this line
but i guess it's just playable for white
since man is playing this right
yeah it's sometimes hard to get an
advantage as white uh in these lines
where
where black just gets a really kind of
solid setup
and then then there's room to outplay
the opponent later on
um i guess the line that we went into
i i kind of stuck with a more
traditional setup bishop e7
yes e3 actually three and yeah we go and
then
at some points at some point i played c6
yeah like this
so i think one yeah so one improvement
for white
is to play one idea is 95 another idea
is to just play h3
um i think you can play it right here
just so that when i play knight f8
i want to play this this and this to get
the bishop pairs so you can play bishop
f4 here
it's kind of a nice idea i don't know
uh and then knight e5 oh but then maybe
knight g6
yes it is actually i was not like until
happy
but i think in this slide you need to
trade maybe 95 earlier
i guess or not here should be a nice
idea i guess
therefore probably
that's true actually yeah usually like
if i get this i'll play that f8
and then like go for some like g4 move i
don't know
something or you can even up for
something this one it should be
irritating for us
for white it should be quite ridden if
he snaps
nothing usually not worse i guess
yeah yeah there's there's like different
ways for black to kind of try and
equalize from these positions but i was
very happy with what we got in the game
because it's like
full preparation um like this is the
most natural plan for light to minority
attack
and in the game when you get the bishop
pair actually
i think you should be i should be better
i can say i mean like my attack
on the queen side is pretty slow
oh wait i mean no no in the game somehow
you should be i played bishop d6 first
right
yes and then we
and somehow i play something here here
and fc1
if it wasn't mistaken yeah you play roxy
one here
and for there's one thing i wanted to
show you because there's a move here
sorry um
oh man here we are here we are okay nice
one here we are here we are there's
instead of rook c1 there's e4 which i
was curious if you considered it
e4o actually is coming
um this would be good for white if not
for black's next move
we should stream something oh no this
doesn't work right now
um not bishop h3 but there there's like
a cool
kind of computer inspired sacrifice
i remember like first discovering this
line the computer doesn't see the idea
right away
but uh is knight f4
f4 allowing e5 yes
and then queen e6 queenie says oh okay
could you force i didn't right no idea
queen g4 yeah so i've had this like
maybe a couple times
just like full full preparation um
and it's not yet fully winning for black
because you have 91
rook takes e1 3 and then f3 yeah
but black is uh like in the very end
black will win the pawn yeah
i think he should really fight at least
um so that was like the full extent of
my my preparation which
i was hoping we'd go into all of it but
i don't know but the position is so far
i guess that like here like 26 i will
play something different i will play
like i guess 92
i guess that oh sure yeah 92 is probably
um
a better move and then oh no
i see something like this one i don't
know if this works ooh
you take on d6 finish
this looks so fun to watch i don't know
why yeah
um that's interesting
queen h3 wow
actually don't know um
this looks really tricky can you stream
let's go this one because the knights
hanging i was thinking knight g3 but
then knight f4 and then four is
crushing g2
but but
oh
it's weird like i was so focused on the
king's side that
it's so easy to forget about the queen
yeah i mean like the early islam like
this one i couldn't do five different 25
defense a night yeah
and this was hanging this loop kind of
moved i mean i see it
but oh my gosh
it's almost working this might be winnie
i don't know but actually
let's okay i think it should be
when this would be losing yeah why it
just has too much counter play
yes it is
yeah i think after 92 the um the the
move is
just to take out three and d3 d3
and then yeah like bishop a6 or even
like bishop f8
like the game goes on but um
i think it's playable for both sides
yeah that's fine i mean like bishop pr
i'm the bishop here yeah i think blaze
fire i guess
a really really interesting lie i can
say that
so yeah it's been a pet line of mine for
like over the over the years to
um to play queen's gamba declined for
some sort of advantage even
because some of these lines get really
tricky yes it is
but a lot of the games you just avoided
any sort of uh opening preparation
which is a little bit frustrating i was
trying to be tricky with uh
as white like with these e4 lines like
against sicilian
i mean like actually the elephant is
quite i mean a nice idea in opening
oh yeah i saw i saw you have like a
course on youtube
on the elephant i mean like
actually the cross might not be that
good but i think
i think it should be quite a nice idea
uh-huh
can i ask you okay do you know the
refutation like is there a refutation to
the elephant i know
i know i mean like actually i'm doing
this cross for i mean like
to find the best thing to do for black
the thing obviously is that
you know true to mostly most gambits
even like the
players know the refutation though they
can be slightly better
but if i hear the best ed5
now if actually it's only listening to
an equalized position
of the queen d5
and now there's two move here for white
to keep pressure right upon e4
just plug the pin nessie 3 is something
i don't think should be really good for
white
i mean like i play this i mean i play
this for a lot recently
and i figure out that knight c3 is
something i love to
face better i think the best light is d3
it's d3 interesting trying to get
e4 with the pawn so now the move
like need to play screen d5 queen d5
now there's two ways to play for white
to win a pawn here my c3 is not that
good since like got this idea to pin
right so you can cast us next but now
you have two moves that you can play
you can choose but like knight t2
yeah but this knight can be played to be
true ah like ft2
is nice but the idea i mean like i'm
trying to still find something for black
since after knight i mean both tonight
to d2 i need something like plus
1.2 for white already okay i mean
i think this one is the best
since right now the move that i want to
release is d4
this is quite irritating something c3
can be a move that you need to consider
i'm trying still trying to work here for
black to fight the you know best play
i think got one actually but it is still
not easy
i mean now here is light's turn we need
to know some stuff
if he doesn't so he will end up in worst
right away
for instance right now like if you
trying to do something fast
so like should be seven for instance
assuming that c3 team e4 next
just three to five for white he can try
should be two and then he castling on
the
queen side actually not the king side
like this also why i can hope for
something like d4
and then this one for instance and then
here a queen b5
and this threat kills all the fights
yeah white
the initiative right away
so uh is there is there a way for black
to keep initiative or you're still kind
of trying to dig through
possibilities yeah i mean actually this
slide is pretty rare i see no one
playing this
so don't be trying to you know deep into
this line i find something usually
but the main light is like queen a5 i'm
not
taking this slide seriously i fancy
three i mean queen of five is the best
thing i guess
and then it takes threatening queen b5
a6
ah okay and this move is so strange i
mean no one played this move
i mean like trying to dig really deep
with the engine
but it's something for blitz like if
you're well prepared
um yes i i love doing stuff like this
playing like
dubious gambits where you're just more
prepared than the opponents
it can be very very effective in blitz
because you get the early time advantage
yes it is i mean like actually this
stuff is so dangerous to play for black
in a classical game you can see that
since if i had enough time you think
he probably is not in some troubles i
mean like
obviously his pieces looks quite safe
and he got no witnesses
he can try and castles right away as
well like need to prove his combination
which most of the time is not enough but
in a short time control game it is going
to be an
interesting weapon that if you are not
ready to face this one
you can be like facing some troubles in
the
opening sure i mean like you know for
instance i play this one against dania
and some
strong oh gm so now i got a trap here
like we need two and f6
let's see three you know this line most
of the guys try and play this one i see
three
take the pawn on e4 this should be
another playable life or white
but need to find some really special
move should be seven
knight four and fastlane black
sacrificing two pawns
to search for color play so now we need
to know
what to do properly d3 95.
we should be two i made this slide a lot
do it and castling here
it seems to be quite safe right it seems
to be that white's king has get out of
the danger
yeah what's up ah
and now i mean like you can be surprised
to see to know that
the best move here by the engine is g3
wow okay no no one's ever finding g3
unless they're prepared
yes but no let's say the knight
okay seems fine so now just question for
you
this is quite easy you can say let your
plan win
back to play and win yes
okay i think i see it but um maybe maybe
people in chat can find it too
obviously we want to exploit the the
e-file
yes um
someone's saying bishop g5 which i think
just runs into bishop takes g5
yes so we want to create a situation
where the discovery is actually
effective
okay it looks like one person in my chat
have has found the move knight c3
yes it is i mean like i even caught
dania
with this thing and i win right away
since my pc three before e3
and bishop g5 simones are queen right
away
yeah so whichever piece takes back we're
going to have a check winning the queen
that's really nice how many times have
you had this in
like an online game i think like three
times online games
one with like the pronunciation of one
as well for enough like
the young from india and then i guess
like 125 or something
i don't know but i do this have this
position that's great three times
and i win bottom three i guess i love
opening traps like this which are like
super rare that can still trap like
really strong players yes i mean
obviously no one can find g3
yeah like the whole line is so natural
for white too and it doesn't look like
white is is taking so much risk going
into this
just to show g3 the point would be after
takes i assume we take
back and then now we have the discovery
yeah i mean they discover again now
somehow this is why to have discovery
also if you're not careful that can be
some idea for instance like
squishy four and nine five or something
like that sure
no smaller idea also the fun thing can
be like
and then like this one for instance
ouch yeah imagine like d7
yes imagining this is funny that's rough
so g3 is best lie and i think for like
if i was start mistaken the line
continue with
96 like this one i mean like the point
that the knight still there
he can't run anywhere if you run with
the rules again
so now we just keep developing first and
then we can even place your effort
if i was domestic and so at the end of
the line why need to keep the knight on
e4 away
interesting but he have some
compensation yeah this looks really
difficult to figure out
in like a blitz game especially if
white's not prepared and you you blitz
out knight c6
that's got to be like you're pretty much
guaranteed the the time advantage like
early on
yes it is i mean that's why basically i
really love some opening with some like
traps like this
sure and also you know like try and play
something dubious in the opening like no
one can know that
and in bliss game that can bring us some
initiatives
you know in terms of images or at least
something that we like know
earlier so there's there's a comparable
opening that i enjoy playing
um that's maybe related to the elephant
gambit like it's dubious
but very very venomous i'm curious if
you've
looked at it it's a stafford gambit
which is
yes okay so you're you're aware of this
uh
this line i wanted to know our first
game
because you played that actually the
thing here is that i mean like somehow
i still find it's like quite easier to
defend for white i mean something like
this one
and then like d3 which e2 i mean like i
think bishop c5
should be three oh there's a cool trap
here
so takes knight g4 g4 okay
nice thing f3 maybe here
this is going to be nice i mean i forget
the main defense but i think it should
be like we should
do something like that i do have a
research in this life of white as well
but i forget
actually that's why i do not dare i mean
like i know you are a specialist here so
i'll share one trap because like the if
you look this up in the
in the online database the most played
move here is king d2
walking into knight takes h2
h2 and then black is winning with queen
e5
nice nice so it's a nice little tactic
really winning
just really winning i mean like after
rook h2 the queen of a1 the queen
a1 seems to be quite i mean trump i
don't know
maybe why have some initiative um engine
will say like minus two i think
minus two uh seems nice but i i don't
know let's go for something
h5 i guess couldn't be two and i see
three
queen one is not this bad for white
though that seems to be
six defend everything and you can cast
like it's still playable
but uh yeah it's a lot more fun for
black
yeah i think that's fine i guess
um and then there's there's a bunch of
other things too like
if white plays safely like inside bishop
e3 bishop b2
is the most played move than each five
five
can you still do this one again
yeah this this is um probably a safer
way of playing but it's still
it's still a little bit tricky because
in the lines where white
takes takes is this queen d6 idea
yes
seems nice this seems nice um okay i
mean
i see something like 22.6 just quite
nine for sure
so this one and then g oh yeah you can't
probably even play this one again
because
there's there's ideas with queen g3
exactly
um so there's a lot of lines where white
tries to play safely where there's this
like weird kind of
um like lasting initiative for black and
a lot of lines black can continue to
make threats
like another line is c3 here
d4 queen h4
a lot of people play g3
engine will say it's already like
completely winning for white but it gets
really messy
yeah bishop g4 there's bishop g4 then
you have to kind of
deal with that position um
and white will have an edge there but
this is a cool line like g3
queen f6 yes f3 and then h4
it's just a big mess that's cool enough
i mean like yeah
somehow it looks like black right away i
mean like the idea japanese file now
seems to be
completely messy and i love to play this
thing like this
thing in this games so i like this one
definitely yeah there's so many lines
like this in the stafford which is why
like i've i really like playing in blitz
and bullets
um and there's like positions pretty
deep in this line which like stockfish
doesn't fully understand
um trying to remember there's some crazy
variations like rook g1
we take
yeah takes takes and then this move like
h2
yes and hit connect here but what about
like this one simply
uh this line and then i have to flip the
board
remember um
so 95 i mean
that looks not that cool for us i don't
know
maybe i'm blind okay i'm gonna have to
check the engine here because
i remember there are oh sorry um not
uh not 95 but bishop e6 is a very key
move
and that's not over and then after queen
d4
amazing move that sockfish won't find
right away is bishop c4
oh oh
there there's a video on youtube i have
to give full credit to uh jonathan
trance
he's like an expert level player but he
discovered this line and
um like lilo will find this before
stockfish
and the idea is if queen c4 and black is
already a5 um the knife and f3
already having uh knight e5 yeah
yes the knight three amazing amazing so
it's like a double piece sack yeah
bishops before you can't really find it
without uh
without the engine yes i mean once again
some really really tricky engine play oh
my gosh
yeah and this is one reason like i like
the stafford is if you're
if you're really deeply prepared like a
lot of players will
will like just walk into your
preparation and you'll get some time
advantage
well yes it is i'm pretty sure that is
the thing that can be
same with mine sicilian intervention
something like e4 c5 not knife six
oh i prepared this for you actually i i
i i only suck with knight f3 though
i forgot to or knight c3 i should have
played that f3
yes i mean suddenly somehow right now
people won't play this against me i
don't know why
but i mean like somehow yeah this line
has been played to me a lot by daniel as
well
interesting danielle played this one to
me every game
oh that's fine i'm ready for this line
since i prefer this one
pretty deep so it's just a bit set that
we don't hit any game in this line
yeah i was gonna play uh e5 knight e5
knight d5 and then bishop c4
this line and knight b6 d3
and it's like it's a really weird way of
playing but i i've heard about this line
from greg shahadi
he was interviewed on like on this
podcast where he was discussing
his approach to like dealing with tricky
openings
and he was saying that he didn't want to
study like the main theory in this so he
just chose like an
offbeat but solid line for white
[Music]
if yeah if like ever takes sentence it's
pleasant for whites
well i don't think i'm ticking i think
i'll play with messy six i guess
yeah i think i saw you had one game in
this against hans neiman
but hans played bishop d3 here which
wasn't uh
wasn't the best move um
yeah this is playable i think for both
sides
but i would play this just to get you
out of your preparation
yes i think i would play like if i play
heroes gonna be three which is a nine
for me i guess
that's true i think i will try and play
like e6 and d5 next i don't know
i think i will probably play this
yeah that probably makes more sense
but this seems to be uh this seems to be
quite tricky for both of us
yeah it's just kind of a weird opening
position that uh
it doesn't really okay actually i mean
when i go for the ninja which i'm ready
for something really really like
offbeats
already makes sense i still remember the
first day i mean the first day i played
this
e4 c5 and then i have three and i mean
like i mean i play this one against
hikaru
first time player he gets hikaru playing
f6 and then he removed
e4 and then you know then
an a4 and then in the chat he was like
oh this guy sucks with this trick
i mean like he doesn't like my trick
obviously he think that i want to
cut his remove but i mean like but
that's your
that's your line anyway gotcha it's my
light every time
and you know that and right now he wants
to play an a3 against me
oh interesting so there is a game hikaru
played this was maybe a decade ago
it was in the us chess league he played
knight f6 himself
you probably know that he lost yeah he
lost in like 11 months
he lost in like 11 or 12 moves yeah
against i know enough
i mean that is one of the things i do
prepare myself mm-hmm e6
95.
so you know the improvements yes d6 i
know i know he said okay
64. in the game he played queen e7 which
is simply
very bad just losing g5 f6 and castling
no no sorry
f6 and castling and he resigned
yeah this is how you beat him i love you
once
and i think he played against i forget
uh julio
yeah i gave a lecture uh covering this
game like years ago at the
st louis chess club it's somewhere on
youtube but uh
it's a beautiful game i i think it's
sakara's like quickest loss
in like a serious uh serious competition
yes i mean like i know i did i
did some work in this line so i know the
defense i'm not worried
also just to address because some people
are asking why is this so bad for black
like why
why does black resign here um
of course people can probably use the
engine to to realize
but uh it simply has a threat of
yeah like black's positions
and you know like the europe is so fast
i mean now it is something that
like cannot defend since like right now
nifa is on the rope
and also when doing a5 so the kings is
open and it cannot run anywhere
and it's been here as well i mean
everything's just falling yeah it's like
black black basically doesn't have a
move here
so um it goes to show the power of
following opening principles
i mean that is something you need to
face and you need to address when you
place
lines when you don't know i mean when
you yourself don't know the theory
i mean when somehow you fall into your
your own variation
i mean that is obviously nothing not the
thing we don't want to fall into
so obviously now i mean
but i mean like this line now i do some
homework so this is the main line
should it say 23 frozen since queen 45
right
23 right knight before this is the main
line
with the idea to play queen e2 c4
contest and rook see it
again i feel like this is fitting the
the whole style of playing something
really offbeat
but really being deeply prepared and now
lights under a lot of pressure
like c2 is hard to to cover in some
lines bishop
choose a threat
i feel inspired i want to um
i want to look into this opening of the
team take steps and counseling
too when black is not worse i mean like
at least it's fine here
we got more octopuses and yeah
uh-oh oh no i think i lost you
the the preparation is so deep that the
internet just couldn't handle it
oh queen d7 okay oh
again yeah no worries i mean luckily i
can fix this stuff in around 10 seconds
yeah it seems to drop for only a few
seconds yes
so this slide is something i know and i
can say that
let's find here but i mean i you know i
do research in this line you know like
for
at least two years i can say before i
play this line
wow in a real game but this is a thing
you can play
in a classical game um oh you remember
the first game i played classical in
this line
which is like back to 2018 and i was
black i was black against like the none
other than the best player in my country
like liam who should be insane as well
you know man
yeah we went to the same university we
both studied at webster
uh so he was my teammate for a couple
years
yes so you know like in i mean in
i mean in the slide so you know when he
played
like we played classical game i took
2018.
so here i'm in s3 and then i make never
sets
and then you know half of the i mean
half of the playing hall was coming here
and they were
like what the hell what the hell is this
and then i mean liam
himself thing for 30 minutes for 30
minutes on move
three i'm up two i mean look three
against that after move two yeah
yes that's crazy did he play e5
yes play e5 energy g3
it's so nice to like surprise opponent
on move two
especially when they're such a strong
player and have them think for so long
not easy to do yes actually in this game
i mean like attending
at the end under the middle game it was
like minus two
and then i failed to convert a winning
position oh
it's like it's just something that you
can play in classical scenes like
you can see even like my media europe
play love games there are
some strong players that play there and
this is really good thing to do for sure
i feel like so many players so many e4
players don't even
take the time to study anything here so
it's already like they're out of
prep on move two and then you like
you're so booked up
actually makes a lot of sense yes it is
well the thing can be said is that like
you know when you play this line so
most of the opponent doesn't know too
sorry
sorry but suddenly right now i mean like
i played this one for three years
so basically like anyone everyone can
know that i'm playing this line gotcha
and you can find my games in you know
online space yes it's easier to find me
playing against like firuja giri arunian
like
on everyone i can say uh-huh
yeah you'll have to come up with some uh
some more like tricky openings like this
where
and take your opponent out of properly
even if they're a little bit dubious
anyway this has been really great yes i
think so i mean like
really having fun and well i think we
would enjoy the message right
definitely yeah i mean for me it was
more like educational
um if if it was closer maybe i would
have been like a lot more competitive
but uh a super fun experience and it's
it's always fun chatting about these uh
kind of offbeat
openings as well yeah no worries i mean
like i also learn a lot of stuff as well
and i mean like i do face a lot of
difficulties in the matches
i mean like my viewers expect me to win
smoothly but i said that like eric is
damn strong he's really underrated and
i mean like i respect her much against
him and obviously in bliss i mean like
in like the first five games
i mean even more in the first six or
seven games i really struggles
i really struggle with the winning games
i guess yeah
i felt like i had some chances early on
um but i'll have to we'll have to do
another one of these and i'll try and
get some
some better score next time i don't know
how much how much
sure i mean like yeah i mean sure i mean
i'm really looking forward
as well and whenever you can feel ready
we can do it again for sure
sounds good yes it is